first we're going to hear from our board
president then the superintendent and
then we'll open it up for questions
and with that border school trustees
president linda cavazos
good afternoon everyone and thank you
for being here today at dean peterson
elementary school
we want to thank principal melissa
gutierrez for hosting us today
also thank you to all of our employee
association presidents
executive directors who have joined us
here today
since last march our school communities
including every student
parent teacher support professional
and community member has had safety on
their minds
physical safety from covid19 and mental
and emotional safety
from the accompanying stress and anxiety
we have suffered
who have been hit very hard by this
virus throughout all this our teachers
our administrators our support
professionals our district staff
our superintendent have kept our schools
open
only our buildings were closed safety
was the number one priority
as we move forward with the huge
challenges that face us as we return
both students and employees to the
physical classrooms
with the choice to continue distance
learning know that we will not back down
from keeping our priorities straight
and that is to keep every student and
employees safe
by working collaboratively toward that
bull goal we are excited
to provide the best possible education
from pre-12 to 12.
they are all our kids they are all our
employees
and they all deserve the best thank you
and i now like to welcome our
superintendent
of ccsd dr jesus f
superintendent
[Applause]
thank you trustee cavazos good afternoon
thank you
for being here i'm going to remove my
mask
just because i got some other high
school principles that i continue to
advertise for
one high school but all all our schools
are important
thank you to the board of trustees some
of them who are here
this afternoon the other ones have other
commitments and they're
doing some great things so um as you can
see from those
are behind me um i am so proud
that i stand with all our bargaining
partners who are here
from mr derek bellow
president of kasapi and executive
director steve ausberger
ccea president marie nice
esea president jan giles captain young
from the police administrators union and
officer caldwell
who is also here um representing our 42
000
employees and i'm telling you before i
get started
i couldn't be more proud of the 42
000 employees that i have the honor to
serve as their superintendent
because what what has occurred in this
past year
is is close to a a miracle
because turning over the fifth largest
district in the country
upside down in distance education to
providing our children
all 310 000 in education
has been a remarkable effort by
every single one from our principals our
teachers our support professionals
and i can't say enough about our support
professionals because we've served close
to 11 million meals
from the first day that we closed our
schools
as i stated for many months i wanted our
schools open
but we needed to do it safely because
i know how important to our community
our kids being in school
on it every single day to our staff to
our parents
the governor's easing of the
restrictions last week
helped speed up the process for us our
team
immediately went to work to look to see
what that meant for our children
and i'm going to provide with a timeline
but before i start on the timeline
i also want you to know that as trustee
cavazos mentioned
not only were we
running a school district through
distance ed we were also planning
on reopening our schools that's why we
immediately
when we could announce that on monday
our pre-k through grade 3 our students
will be coming in on a hybrid model
as i talked to some of the elementary
school principals
as i visited our teachers are so excited
our staff
is so excited to welcome our babies
to a face-to-face instruction under
hybrid instructional model
on march 22nd
grade 6 grade 9
and grade 12 will be coming back to
school
under hybrid instructional model
april 6 grade 7
8th 10th and 11th will return
to school under a hybrid model
april 6th all
pre-k through grades five will come to
school
five days a week parents
please know that we will continue to
offer
full-time distance education to our
families
who feel more comfortable keeping their
children
at school so let me talk about
some of the other improvements actually
expansions and things we're going to
continue to do
many of our families have a lot of
questions about athletics
and extracurricular activities our
athletic department
who are here with us have been working
with niaa
and the governor's office at this time
we will continue and we will start to
offer
spring sports that will start april
3rd these are the same kids that last
year
missed their spring season games and
meets will begin
april 16th the sports include
track boys and girls swimming boys and
girls diving baseball softball
boys golf and boys fall volleyball
we also working with our athletics
department
plan to offer schools the opportunity to
offer
inter-mural athletics for the fall
season those sports include football
tennis boys and girls soccer
boys and girls cross country boys and
girls
and girls volleyball there will be two
different windows
april 5th and may 1st
football only full contact
the earlier window is needed for yearly
helmet and pad reconditioning of
helmets and our shoulder pads
again to get them ready in time for the
fall
of 2021 football will have 20 practice
competition
during this window culminating
an inter-squad game lasting at least one
hour
this gives our student athletes
focus on the word student athletes an
opportunity to showcase their stuff
their talents our coaches to be able to
record their videos for college
recruiting it will be similar
to a spring game within their own school
may 3rd through 22nd all other fall
sports
staggered against to give our children
an opportunity
to play and not have to choose between a
single sport
no spectators will be allowed at
any ccsd athletic event
school clubs will also resume with
online
with in-person learning
we will follow all safety precautions
following ccsd's the state
cdc guidelines and the niaa
all coaches and adults associated with a
team
will have to have a negative test for
covid
before activities begin what is
happening now
since moapa valley high school currently
practicing
for in since they've been in person and
virgin valley high school
who will transition to in person march
8th
will start practicing march 1st must
have 10 days of practice
before the start of the competition
our students who participate in the
performing arts
students will be able to engage in live
learning
and traditional rehearsals safety
protocols will be implemented to ensure
the safest possible
return to face-to-face instruction
similar to athletics
students will be permitted to engage in
outside of class activities rehearsals
like marching band
drill team and theater to ensure
continued safety of our community our
performing arts will have the option to
engage in streaming
of their concerts for the immediate
future
reopening of schools folks bringing back
staff
and students and continuing distance
education
models requires a lot of logistics
and consideration and top of that safety
of our employees and of our students
something that we need to remind this
community we have 1700 bus routes
1700 bus routes with restrictions
so we have been planning our staff
has been doing an amazing job
of getting this community and our
children
back to school i am proud of the work
that our team has put together working
with our trustees
to bringing our students back to school
safely all ccsd employees
will return to their work sites no later
than march
15th all of this information will be
posted
on our website underpin
our reconnect our parents and our
community has
already received an email so let me
transition a little bit before we turn
it over to questions
for our families in spanish
espanol
and now i'll open it up to questions and
you can have
anybody here from all our bargaining
partners also our chief negotiator and
our deputy
are here you can ask any questions i'll
turn it over for you to ask
any questions of this great team to the
community
our parents thank you for your advocacy
i continue to keep you and hope
to keep you engaged as we focus on our
academic achievement
as well as our athletic and our
performing arts so thank you very much
so thank you for the question um so the
board approved the
small groups and i think when we look at
some of these plans
um as we continue to start bringing more
kids in
this was part of the uh the switch if
you will i don't want to say a bait
switch but it's really
we have so many bus rides and we have to
prioritize it getting our students into
school
and this was part of the transition that
we work with our building principles
to make sure that our students were in
school and this is we
we decided to go with the sixth grade
the ninth grade and the twelfth grades
most immediate at this time
so um when we looked at our kids so you
look at our sixth graders that have not
been in a school
um in their middle schools all year and
our high school uh ninth graders as well
it was an opportunity for us to get our
kids in for a week
to transition into our middle schools in
high school before
our upperclassmen showed up and what do
you say to families who think this is
all about money getting
students back there that's that's uh
couldn't be the furthest thing from the
truth listen to me i i'm gonna tell you
this is something that we have been
agonizing
um for a long time um to get our kids
in front of our teachers i tell you our
staff
has been finding ways to get this done
um they care they want to see there's
nothing like replacing the face-to-face
um interaction with our children and i
think
it has nothing to do with money as a
matter of fact i was on the phone with
the state superintendent in meetings
today
um but at 7 30. this is really about
getting our kids in school
and getting our kids active i know that
they've suffered enough
our staff has suffered enough and and is
the furthest thing from the truth
of trustees my chief negotiator can
answer that question
the moas are currently being drafted and
reviewed
sorry the moas are being drafted and uh
basically proof read at this point
i believe that if not the presidents or
the unions themselves by vote are
currently approving them all and they're
been
explained to the board and then the
physical document should be to them
within the next
24 to 30 hours
oh sorry vakisha miller
with the return to full-time instruction
from pre-k through grade five how does
this fit in line with the governor's
directive that says they can only have
up to 75
capacity in the classroom and after
they've been in session with
some form of in-face in-person learning
for 20 days
so as our kids return to school march
1st next monday
it fits right into the timeline um for
that's why they're coming in april 6
uh for the uh five days instruction but
on april 6 will the classrooms be at 100
capacity will they be in 75
capacity let me turn it over to my
deputy superintendent
hello brenda larson mitchell so um the
governor's directive indicated that
schools had to be in session for 20 days
of
in-person face-to-face instruction and
then we could move to the 75
capacity um one of the things that we
are reviewing
um currently is that three feet versus
six feet social distancing
um when you look at the six feet social
distancing with fifty percent capacity
it doesn't provide you with much more
but with that seventy five percent
capacity we will have the ability to
bring in more children
but also considering that three feet to
six feet four
safety and health precautions
well we gotta look at where we are you
know our safety our mitigation
strategies our
our re our partnership with the state um
is you know we have to go through the
contact racing and hopefully
you know that would be a goal as long as
we're
so safe school students should expect
cyprus through the end of the year
but no expectation for full time right
right now kristen is uh we're looking at
to see how
how this works out but this is the
immediate plan at this point
certainly looking at it you know
potentially for the end of the year but
what can you say about graduation
ceremonies and then
yeah nice jackie that's a great question
our team has been working and trying to
get ahead and being proactive
i know we sent communication for schools
to do their graduations and plan to do
that
before the governor's restrictions so
now we're going back
to see what the potential would be about
some of our graduations
and more to come after we get our
schools open
how many students will stick to the
full-time distance learning education
thank you so currently we have about
sixty percent and forty percent
so we are looking at forty percent of
our pre-k through three
engaging in full-time distance education
and also for our secondary students it
is about forty percent
as well full-time distance education
will there be a survey going
out to the secondary school families
asking whether they want
distance no we're going to
use the data we had from the last survey
for our secondary schools
uh our principles you know i have the
faith the full faith that our principles
will be able to accommodate our children
those who want to move back and make
some decisions
we we have to you know we i said it
earlier we were distance education now
we're transitioning we're still running
a school district
distance edge so our principals will be
able to do that we have meetings
scheduled for
friday to start working on the details
of this plant
a
foreign
foreign
yeah one of the things jeremy i failed
to mention our teachers and our staff
will come in march 15th
for the week just like our elementary
schools they they came in this past
monday to get ready
for the week i i'm gonna tell you um i
couldn't be
that i've said it many times um our
teachers
you know they've been preparing our kids
to come to school face to face they're
they're so excited i've been in schools
up and they've been planning for this
day but i think
i have the full confidence of our
employees to get our kids ready
so many petitions have been online we've
seen protests for months from parents
how big of a
factor was parental uh
i guess some groups said advocacy uh
towards
getting these students back in the
classrooms you know this is uh
what i love about this community um and
their engagement and advocating for kids
um i welcome that and i and i i want
them to continue to advocate about
academics just as they have for
athletics
up and that's one of the things that i'm
excited about i want to engage them
as we continue to work together to get
our kids because i'm going to say this
our kids our staff i feel i i
at least i feel energized that there's a
lot of support from our community so i
welcome to stay engaged with us as we
bring our kids back because our kids are
going to need this entire
community to art to wrap their arms
around them
to get them to succeed academically just
as they're going to succeed athletically
and just as they're going to succeed in
their performing arts it's not one thing
and
and i'm i'm so excited that they're
engaged
that's part of the planning that we've
had um the ppes are
are ready we've we've had them purchased
now you know we started rolling them out
to school when
uh for our pre-k three so that's
something that
it's been funded i've been working the
team has been working with the
governor's task force to make sure that
we have enough ppes for our staff and
our students
well we we still uh you know we still we
have enough
um you know and again in the close
conversations with the governor's office
they have opened their office for us
on a 24 7 uh whatever we need and it's
not just ppe
it's contact tracing is is covet 19.
look look i you know the the
vaccinations for our staff
um they prioritize our educators and and
i'm proud of the work that they have
done on behalf
of our kids how important was it to give
spring sports athletes a chance to play
this season after they
encounter season cancer last year well
that's one of the things that when when
our athletic department when we were
looking at these are kids that missed
out last year and they they're
you know it was one of the things that
um we were concerned about missing two
years of athletics and competition
but one of the things that you know i
get as a former coach
i get how important athletics is um and
i think it was
it was one of the factors that we're
looking to to bring our student athletes
in
um but then i also look at you know
where as we're planning for those kids
that missed the fall
this past season that that's in the
middle for the other students in
northern nevada
we're giving our kids a unique
opportunity under niaaa rules
for our kids to be able to at least have
some contact to get ready for fall 2021.
well before the pandemic i can't predict
that but i'm going to tell you this is
one of the things that as we continue
to open safely um
slowly carefully is not to go backwards
um it's to go forward whether we come to
five days a week in our secondary
schools i don't i can't answer that it
all depends on the mitigation strategies
that i know that we have
great ones in place my goal is that
we're in face-to-face instruction when
we open school next year
did i hear you say to 16 000
of your employees have been vaccinated
if so can you also tell can you
give us a breakdown how many of those
were teachers
i don't have that in my head but we can
get that information to
whoever wants it melinda will get that
and that's through the unlv pod
uh we have i think a larger number
through southern nevada health district
and we can look in china that's
something at the data point we're trying
to get what actions have you taken to
support
student mental health for students i
heard from a school yesterday that only
have one counselor
teachers have not gotten any knee
training
so what i can tell you is that this is
one of the reasons and i'm proud of the
work that the
school board of trustees have done in
approving panorama
which is a universal screener um that
has gone to all schools
are all you know we've had we started
with 12 schools and a pilot for lifeline
and that has expanded to 68 our schools
have
really provided some support for for our
students as far as the counselor to
student ratio
you know look that's and i know trustee
cavazos and and the board has had
many discussions around this um you know
we need more support that's nothing that
i'm going to shy away from uh the board
also approved
in an moa with our teachers ccea to
increase the pay for psychologists
that has been done um you know and we've
had conversations with the federal
delegation
uh this is not you know given our
economy given where we are with the
state
this has got to be a federal investment
for our families and for our kids
can you clarify can you clarify on just
staggered
sports to avoid forcing students to play
a single sport
it's my athletic directors who have more
expertise ms sloane
thank you tim jackson what was the
question again
to avoid forcing students to choose a
single sport
what is that how can you clarify
the staggered question is very good um
the spring sports start april 3rd
officially through niaa
staggering them allows students to then
go out
try out commit to a sport in the spring
without having the conflict of an
intramural program run at the exact same
time
where they may feel the pressure to
choose one or the other
we follow statistics statistics say
students that participate in multiple
sports are more successful
we've created a viable option for kids
to do two sports
at the exact same time under the niaa
guidelines
second question was was there any
consideration basketball in wrestling
absolutely one of the things we looked
at was availability of club activities
to our students football doesn't have
club activities
the same way basketball does i'm not
discounting basketball
but the kids had a lot more opportunity
there was no
way we could offer all 22 varsity sports
in one window so what we did was we
addressed what was coming up next
which was fall of 2021 and intramural
season
is a part of that preparation every
season
so the winter sports will not miss out
on an intramural
theirs will occur as it has
traditionally occurred in october
into november it's just been
calendarized now for football
in a in an attempt to give those kids
that opportunity which they've never had